it's great to be joined today by dr.
Hagee Levine
who is from Hebrew University Hadassah
School of Public Health he's also the
lead author of a meta-analysis into what
is happening with sperm count and male
fertility
dr. Levine it's so great to talk to you
you know I've been reading more and more
about this issue and I think it's one
that a lot of people may not even know
is going on so let's introduce the
audience to what you've been studying
what trend are you seeing with in sperm
count and male fertility around the
world well if I may before I start I
actually start my presentation with the
famous statue of David and this is to
mention that we are interested in male
fertility not only of Kings for many
years however for some reason we totally
neglected male fertility now what's
important about the trend of sperm count
before we get to the results is that
sperm count is not only a great
indicator for male fertility it's also
influenced a lot by the environment so
we can learn from it about the impact of
the environment on human health and more
than that recent studies have shown that
sperm count and semen quality is a
predictor of morbidity and mortality so
if we have a problem with sperm count it
suggests that we have problem with men's
health in general so against this
background we wanted to know what are
the trends of sperm counts around the
world now 25 years ago there was a
seminal paper by Carlson and others
which claimed that there is a decline in
sperm count at least in Western
countries however this paper was
received with a lot of criticism and
there was still a debate so what we try
to achieve is to systematically review
the literature we screened over
7,500 papers to get all the papers with
good data on sperm count and to model
the trends over time this is called a
meta-analysis and what were the results
that you found when doing this
meta-analysis so the results were
shocking no matter how we analyze the
data there was over fifty percent
decline in both sperm concentration and
total sperm count among men from Western
countries over the last 40 years imagine
any indicator human indicator that
declined by 50 percent in 40 years when
we modelled only studies after 1995 the
trend was even steeper and this is after
controlling for various factors such as
age and abstinence time so if we you
know if we summarize it houston we have
a problem we have a problem with sperm
count among men from Western countries
unfortunately we simply don't have
enough data to know what are the current
trends among men from non-western
countries yeah so one question was going
to be what do we know about men from
non-western countries you've sort of
preempted that by saying we don't
exactly know can you talk a little bit
about within Western countries are there
any other trends whether they are
demographic trends whether they are
particular countries is it most
unnoticeable within any other subgroups
that you've looked at so I am a
scientist as a scientist I focus on the
facts and the fact is that in this study
our aim was to study the trends and I
cannot say based on this study what may
be the cause or what are the populations
or countries
with the largest decline so
unfortunately this study at any study is
limited to answer the question is there
a decline or not and what is the
magnitude however for my studies and
from other people studies we can say
something about your question so we know
many of the problems that harm sperm
count and harm male fertility we know
that male reproductive health is
determined mainly in two periods in life
in the fetal period when the main
reproductive system is developing and
this time you need a very specific
cascade of hormones in order for the
testicles to develop properly and we
know that even one part per million one
drop in a swimming pool of an endocrine
disruptor could disrupt this development
and manifest later on in life as low
sperm count or as testicular cancer or
other problems of the male reproductive
system so we know that exposure to
chemicals such as dilates we note that
exposure to stress we know that maternal
smoking all this could in harm and
testicular development and could be some
of the explanation for the decline we
see in sperm count which means that when
we look for the causes we should not
only look at the causes over the last 40
years but we should go maybe 78 years
and look what happened in the world and
we know that during this time there was
a b c d epidemic there was massive
exposure of the population to new
chemicals man-made chemicals that we
were never exposed before and some of
them were proven to disrupt development
of the hormonal system of the testicular
system
on the Huzur on the other hand also
during adult life men produce sperm by
millions every day it's amazing
there is spermatogenesis process which
takes about 80 days so if an adult man
like you David is exposed to chemicals
or to smoking or is obese or is not
physically active it effect directly is
spermatogenesis and his semen quality
and we could also look for some of these
reasons and we know that men nowadays
are more more obese and much less
physically active so this could also be
part of the of the causes of the sperm
decline what I think we have to do we
have to acknowledge that this is a major
public health problem on the global
level but also on the personal level
this is an opportunity for each one of
us to promote our own health which will
improve our health and improve our
fertility as well and we need to take
steps beside doing much more research
because we know very little about men's
reproductive health we need to to take
steps to protect ourselves from
chemicals from smoking from obesity and
and certain foods and be more active so
let's let's see if we can explore a
couple of the ways in which this has
consequences so when it comes to human
reproduction as you mentioned we're
talking about the production of sperm
cells by the millions you only need one
in order to have a baby so conceivably
we could say that the impact is not
necessarily the greatest when it comes
to human reproduction because there's a
sort of significant buffer built in
because you produce millions if you
divide that by two it's still millions
you just need one but it seems as though
this issue is connected to many other
areas of health for men is that true or
do you believe that I'm wrong that it is
an issue for human reproduction
so you know as we say you're both right
and one so this is the storm claim and
the problem now it's only the tip of the
iceberg
the problem may continue if we don't
understand what are the causes
I'm not saying but other people saying
if you take the same graph by 2050 we'll
reach zero and so I don't want to
predict the future we don't know what
will happen in the future but even if
there is a chance of 1% that this
decline will continue and we'll you know
almost complete lack of sperm we
definitely need you know to do something
about it yeah at that point it will be a
problem for reproduction right also also
I know for my friends and maybe you and
I of us know from their friends that
nowadays many couples have problem
conceiving they take them longer time
and many of them need assisted
reproduction now you know the animals
while they don't use assisted
reproduction we and we think we are you
know the best animal in the world we are
unable to do the most basic function of
life to reproduce we need technology in
order to reproduce and the most common
fact oh when you study couples that have
problem conceiving the most common
problem is a male factor so I mean it's
40 percent coding you know different
studies but 40 percent male factor 30
percent female factor and 30 percent
combined or unknown factor so this is a
huge problem nowadays many men nowadays
are subfertile which is a bit under the
radar because we don't talk about it and
it's neglected we don't admit it and we
have technological solutions so the
problem is already now but besides that
my point that this is a very important
indicator it means that we have a
problem with our way of living that
seriously disrupt a major
function and if we don't understand what
are the causes and reverse them we will
continue to be insulted and this goes
together with increased in many
different kinds of cancer in specific
congenital malformations and in men
cells in general so as an indicator you
know we need to do something about it
now also about the first issue just to
say when you go before 40 million for ML
studies shows that you start to be
subverted now the mean got from 99 to 47
it means that a huge proportion is below
40
so clearly already now the percentage of
men that are sub fertile is definitely
larger than it used to be 50 years ago
so we need to do something about it
because of fertility issues because of
health issue and because it reflects a
problem that we need to acknowledge okay
in the very limited time we have left I
would love to hear from you I know you
said we don't know what is causing it
but can you give us some sense of what
some of the studies are looking at in
other words are we talking about diet
are we talking about pharmaceuticals are
we talking about environmental factors
are we talking about all of these things
so first we looked at sperm count but
maybe also the sperm function is
hampered maybe one sperm that belong to
a population that is smaller that what
used to be before
maybe is also damaged in some way and we
do have studies answering your question
we do have Studies on
endocrine disrupting chemicals which
hints that they not only empower and
impair the quantity but also the quality
we see epigenetic changes in the single
sperm so
personally I am studying and I'm worried
about the impact of pesticides and of
phthalates and other man-made chemicals
on our fetal development especially of
the male and on our you know on our
bodies during adult life and we are
doing a mass experiment on human
population exposing them for the first
time to many many chemicals that
interact together and maybe some of them
are very harmful not only to ourselves
but also also to next generations and
the effects may be transgenerational so
personally I am very worried about
chemicals and I think we should do much
more
not only in studying these chemicals but
also reversing the burden of proof I
think that before you introduce a
chemical to mass abuse and exposure of
the public it's your obligation to show
that is harmless nowadays you can use
any chemicals exposed many people and
unless you see the bodies and have a
clear proof that it's harmful there is
no regulation so that's my main worry
together with that I think that we can
do much better job in public health in
preventing obesity improving our diet
eating less processed food being more
physically active fighting tobacco and
there smoking all of these factors that
clearly harm our personal and public
health and also made fertility we've
been speaking with dr. Hagee Levine he
is at Hebrew University's Hadassah
School of Public Health thank you so
much for talking to us about this issue
today
thank you David it was a pleasure